hi I'm RIA I'm a pasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy here today it's
roads you must completely use the food
given you can only add to the food you
can buy whatever ingredients you wish oh
here's a new role you must make a
dessert for fancy holiday party let's
see what we are making fancy today box
brownie mix I've never intentionally had
box brownie before it's not very fancy
not much
chocolaty flavor you still have to mix
with water oil eggs it doesn't save you
much time brownie it's a little bit too
casual for holiday parties
I want to elevate it I want to make it a
little bit more festive I've got some
great ideas and as always I'm excited to
make it fancy okay guess what I got
heavy cream cocoa powder fresh
cranberries rosemary
X dark chocolate chips and my favorite
Cattleman's from the pantry I got sugar
powdered sugar baking powder cream of
tartar vanilla extract and brandy let's
get started make it fancy Holiday
Edition
okay first step use cranberries the best
gift I really what do you make getting
fancy today I'm making box brownies box
Ronnie's already fancy do you have any
Christmas traditions here
I usually bake cookies as a gift
oh yeah well I've never gotten any
goodness before why is the first time
I'm even use I to give you this year um
you know my tradition is mainly to just
chill well thank you for stopping by a
lot of course and you know I will be
back for the season finale if I dry you
cook that's we're gonna go head-to-head
that's right you can't get rid of me
I believe in you know to make it fuzzy
bye guys
I'm gonna miss her but I have to keep
cooking I'm using 1 cup of water equal
amounts of sugar turn the heat up and
let the sugar dissolve and make a little
bit thicker we do celebrate Christmas in
Japan but it kind of became a romantic
holiday somehow Christmas Eve is like
couple goats do nice dinner so sugar has
dissolved I'm gonna use 6 cranberries so
you're gonna just put like 30 seconds
just coat it evenly and a scoop it up
weeds throat its man and next use some
rosemary also this is not cooking it's
just down coating and set it aside let
it sit for about 30 minutes to 1 hour
and the next thing I'm going to use box
brownie mix 3/4 cup and quarter cup of
cocoa powder 1/2 teaspoon of baking
powder do you want to shift the dry
ingredients because it's like a little
bit hard part you don't wanna put in a
cake I move on to the wet ingredients 6x
I'm going to separate when egg yolk
mixes in equine it doesn't whip well so
make sure you're just adding egg whites
the quarter teaspoon of cream of tartar
da will help baby lights take what I
wrote a cup of sugar gradually it's
gonna take a little bit long time I'm
going for stiff peaks so this is stiff
peak mix egg yolk next 1 teaspoon of
vanilla and cool thing I recently
learned this is exactly 1 teaspoon so
you don't need to use measurement spoon
you see it's done and it's like pale
white color now out of this egg yolk
mixture and I'm going to all the dry
ingredients
little by little make sure you are like
folding with spatula gently no I have
never met Santa I like the weather
forecast you can track where it's the
Santa do you know what I'm talking about
does anyone know what I'm talking about
it seems like everything is well
incorporated
so butter is ready for this into a pan
you want to spray the pan the parchment
paper and pour the butter and I'm going
to use offset spatula spreading butter
evenly baked this 375 cm high for ten
minutes and I'll be back
cake it's baked and it has been cooled
for about 10 minutes it's cool to the
touch by it's still long and you want to
run the knife so it's not sticking to
the pan transfer to dish towel
you're gonna start rolling so basically
we are training this cake to hold the
shape but this has to cool for 30
minutes and after you roll make sure the
theme is on the bottom side and while we
are waiting I'm going to move on to next
step heat up some cream I will need a 1
cup I'm going to start like medium heat
put chocolate chips maybe seeds 2 cups
so I'm gonna just use an awl so when you
start seeing like little bubbles pour
over the chocolate you want to steep so
hot cream kind of melts that your clay
it's been the two minutes i'ma start
whisking okay ganache looking good do
this in a refrigerator about 30 minutes
so I'm gonna need a two cup of heavy
cream 2 tbsp of powdered sugar 2 copies
a lot of creams I'm going to use
Hannah mixer and finish weights whisk so
I want to whisk until softly hey it's
almost ready so I'm going to switch to
this it's almost soft piece right now
and I like that
chuckling I'm adding on quarter cups you
just fold it so the feeling it's done
I'm going to keep this in the
refrigerator until I use it we have some
brownie mix left over I'm going to just
make it for a decoration 1/2 cup of oil
2 tbsp of water and 2x this is my first
time making box brownie I feel like it's
just a cake in a square shape spray so
we did a little bit research brownie
what's indeed it's American that are
invented in Chicago okay so I'm going to
bake in oven we are back with the cake
it's called off-limits this cake has
been trained to be rolled so it's easy
and you want to take off this paper
spread cream just wanted to make sure
it's gonna be even so using ice cream
scoop you don't want to put cream in the
beginning so it's rolls well using like
little spatula and a small adjustment
I'm going to start rolling I'm gonna
make it tight about its dishtowel it's
my little cake baby putting a
refrigerator ganache is cold and I want
to make it a little bit fluffy so I'm
going to add powdered sugar and brandy 1
tablespoon 2 tablespoons of powdered
sugar
on the Brender shiny and fluffy so this
aside so cranberries are sets I'm going
to call them with sugar it looks really
cute and like very wintry I'm the type
of the person filming New Year's
resolution and forget about it
three days later every year I promise
myself this year I'm gonna drive on
highway I haven't achieved it but maybe
this year 2020 you might see me on the
highway right beautiful kind of look
like you dropped cranberries and
rosemary in snow these are the brown
needs that I baked earlier and cakes
it's chilled it's like unwrapping a gift
almost like opening a present when
you're cutting cake put knife in a hot
water so it cuts well wipe the water
nice spiral you do the other way set
this aside I'm gonna crumble this
brownie I baked earlier I just wanted to
make look like a dark I'm gonna transfer
this using the spatula transfer the
ganache
you don't need to go to think I think
you just wanted to get a nice layer feel
like I'm paint on now I'm gonna be a
sculptor now using the folk and kind of
give a line it doesn't need to be a
perfect you can't even do like wavy you
just wanted to make it look like a tree
so now I'm going to put some decorations
the frosted cranberries looks good looks
very festive cut the top of the rosemary
and insert into the cake to finish I'm
going to sprinkle some powdered sugar so
it kind of look like snow and I'm done
you
fancy dessert for fancy holiday party
[Music]
happy holidays this is what I look like
at every holiday still kind of reminds
me of like some secrecy call me a turtle
again okay this is beautiful thank you
[Music]
wait what are these candied cranberries
yeah you know what I've never actually
it's very hard but it's good fancy what
is this this is a Yule Log yeah very
patchy dish yeah very fancy lady yeah I
love the holidays so thank you for
having you love Holly do I do the duck
on her shirt why needs to difference
between elephant
[Laughter]
[Music]
well you made a fancy as always thank
you you ever like a holiday version of
making the make the fence pick make it
fancy your fancy treats have lured me
all the way down from the North Pole no
nice texture huh about your log I think
this is about the fanciest dish I've had
all year they'll be able to go this is
quite a treat anybody out there that's
watching this some Christmas Eve you
don't have to leave me cookie you know
you've always been on the nice list
about done now you're on my
jingo
- - right
[Music]
you